[Music]
money
we spend our existence chasing it in the
modern world
yet hardly any of us knows how it works
how the idea of money has changed over
time
and how we're on the precipice of the
next evolution of money
an evolution that's either gonna be
really dystopian or one that might set
us free
and the main player fighting for a more
dystopian financial future
china
[Music]
the 11th century bce china invents one
of the first modern forms of money
a cast copper coin it was found
in a tomb belonging to the shang dynasty
metal coins have their advantages
they are durable hard to counterfeit and
they hold intrinsic value
eventually these coins evolved into the
iconic coins with a square hole in the
middle
this was so they could be carried on a
string for large transactions
traders were counting strings of coins
kind of like rows of quarters today
but the problem was they can get pretty
heavy and bulky and if you wanted to buy
something that costs let's say half of a
coin
well it's kind of hard to split a middle
coin on the spot if you don't have
smaller denominations
so during the tang dynasty from 1618 to
907 ce
china invents the next evolution of
money traders started leaving those
strings of coins behind to a trustworthy
agent
that trustworthy agent would then record
how much money the trader deposited on a
piece of paper
and the trader would hang onto that
piece of paper to use in place of
physical coins
that piece of paper would be known as
receipt money and today that trustworthy
agent can be not so trustworthy
and goes by the name of a banker the
song dynasty
970 the 1279 ce the problem with all
these independent bankers was that all
their receipt money was different and
not standardized
a received for coins from one banker
could be not as trustworthy as from
another banker
so the song dynasty started licensing or
approving specific banks people could
leave their coins for receipts at
think of it like state approved banks
and in the 1100s
china again brought forth the next stage
of money the song dynasty took direct
control of the banking system away from
private operators
to issue the world's first government
produced paper money
called zhao si today's idea of money
started in china
and today it's also china who's waging
war financially and by force mind you
to control the next evolution of money
will a decentralized cryptocurrency
that's out of the hands of governments
and central banks come out on top
or will it be a digital currency that's
100 controlled tracked and manipulated
by the chinese government
china's anti-bitcoin we are at a fork in
the road
the path we choose for this
re-imagination of money will forever
shake the very nature of how society is
structured
and china's version is already up and
running
[Music]
crypto's decentralizing ai is
centralizing or if you want to frame it
you know more ideologically you could
say that crypto is libertarian
and ai is communist and of course we
always hear only the first half because
we're biased to the left
but you know ai is communist in the
sense that it's about big data
it's about big um governments
controlling all the data
knowing more about you than you know
about yourself so a bureaucrat in moscow
could in fact set the prices of potatoes
in a leningrad and hold you know the
whole system together
and you know if you look at the you know
chinese communist party it loves ai and
hates crypto so it actually
actually fits if you've seen the social
dilemma
you know how much intimate knowledge
companies have on you these days
and how they use that data against you
in ways you're not always consciously
aware of
that's where today's video sponsor comes
in mine and trust me guys this one is
cool and free so you're gonna want to
learn about this
mine is a smart data assistant that
helps you discover which companies have
your personal data
and it allows you to decide where you
want to keep it all you have to do is
sign in with the email you want to
analyze and boom
i had 186 companies that had my personal
data with a ton of them being ones i
don't use anymore or even know about
then you scroll through the companies
that have your data and choose the ones
you want to get rid of
like this one that i don't use anymore
but the industry's breach potential is
high
and it has my financial information and
with the click of a button
mine allows you to send a deletion email
directly from your inbox
to the company you want your data to be
deleted at and if you change your mind
you can always cancel that request
within the first hour
the more data you have out there the
more susceptible you are to data
breaches hacks and getting your identity
stolen
and mine makes it easier than ever to
minimize your risk and exposure online
and the best part mine is completely
free right now so there's really no
excuse to not take ownership of your
personal data and manage it on an
ongoing basis
they'll be switching to a subscription
model soon so get in while you can while
still free with the link below
that's saymine.com with the link below
2nd 1945 world war ii ends and the us
dollar quickly becomes the reserve
currency of the world
this means that central banks around the
world mainly keep their money in u.s
dollars
and it's the primary currency used for
international transactions
investments and all aspects of the
global economy
this puts the us in a very advantageous
position they can do things like
pressure swiss banks to abandon their
banking secrecy
sanctioned iran and north korea for the
nuclear programs crippling their
economies
applies sanctions against more than 250
chinese nationals that the us accuse of
genocide or threatening the freedom of
hong kong
from china's point of view the usd as
the world's reserve currency is not good
for their sovereignty
2004 alibaba and jack ma launch alipay
a mobile wallet app that lets users pay
for almost anything with a qr code on
their phone
alipay would grow to monopolize the
mobile payments market
2009 bitcoin is invented
and while most nations downplayed the
significance of bitcoin
china paid attention 2013
alipay overtakes paypal as the world's
largest mobile payments platform
while at the same time wechat china's
messaging app that is used for almost
everything
launched its own mobile wallet wechat
pay
2014. china's top central banker
chozhuan
said bitcoin both dazzled and frightened
him so he launched a study to look at
the potential for a chinese digital
currency
2017 bitcoin has its infamous rally to
nearly twenty thousand dollars
and the idea that maybe the world might
not have to rely on central banks and
governments for money is implanted into
the minds of the public
while at the same time alipay and wechat
pay explode in popularity
citizens are relying less on cash and
more on these tech giants as they start
to gobble up all the market share for
mobile payments
and all that juicy data that comes with
processing online payments
what you buy when you buy the
implications of those purchases
and what the chinese government always
being hyper-vigilant against anything
that threatens their power
their focus on a chinese digital
currency intensifies
2019 facebook announces that it's going
to launch its own cryptocurrency libra
that its 2 billion users at the time
could use to transact on the platform
the idea that a tech giant with nearly
seven times the population of the us
that already has a treasure trove of
data launching a currency that could
threaten the us's graphs on the world's
financial system
didn't sit well with regulators so while
the us focused their efforts on stopping
facebook's power grab
china accelerated theirs 2020
it all crescendos china becomes the
leader in mobile payment adoption
alipay and wechat pay submit their
positions as a duopoly in the space
with alipay taking out 54 of market
share and wechat pay taking up 39
of market share altogether mobile
payments make up for more than half of
all non-cash retail payments in china
alipay and wechat pay were striking
exclusive deals with merchants so
customers could only pay with their apps
and just the sheer power of the data
they're collecting is the stuff of
dreams for any authoritarian government
if you knew exactly what when and where
everyone in your economy bought and sold
with the power of big data ai and their
existing surveillance state and social
credit score
you could theoretically control and plan
not just the economy
but the entire population you can catch
and track what you deem as criminal
financial activity you can reward good
economic behavior and punish bad ones
you can give and take money away
directly from citizens
it was a dream that was out of the hands
of the chinese government
and behind the black boxes of these
private tech giants
on top of that alipay's parent company
and group started offering other
financial services like loans on the
back end
and with all their data and leverage
traditional financial institutions had
no chance of competing
although the chinese government does
have ultimate control over these tech
giants and they have to send their data
to the government
it's still a black box the data is still
delayed the data is still in the hands
of powerful people the government might
not be able to trust
and these tech giants were starting to
take over many functions of the
traditional banking system and even the
government
so within just a few years the
government's grasp on the financial
system came under attack from both
crypto and their very own tech giants
and in april 2020 trials for the digital
un launched
compared to alipay wechat pay or
something like a credit card where
you're just moving money around
electronically
china turned the actual money itself
into computer code
and to top it all off on october 24 2020
jack ma the man behind alipay said
china's current banking system operates
with a pawnshop mentality
that chinese financial regulations are
outdated that we cannot use the way to
manage a railway station to manage an
airport
the message to the chinese government
was clear these fintech giants were
starting to get too
arrogant too powerful too comfortable
they were out shouting the master
so the government cut them down a notch
jack ma disappears
the company that owns alipay and group
raised a record-setting 34.5 billion for
its ipo
which would have made it the biggest ipo
of all time until the government shut it
down
and since jack ma's reappearance in
january ma has not made another public
appearance since which brings us to
[Music]
today
since the start of the initial digital
un trials
more than a hundred thousand people have
downloaded the government's mobile app
and it does have some advantages over
alipay and wechat pay
for one your money can be withdrawn from
a state bank there are no transaction
fees for merchants unlike the tech
giants
and in the future they plan to make it
work even when you don't have an
internet connection
and since it's all digital the only
limit to what the government can do with
the digital un
is what they can program in code just
like any other software
they've already started testing digital
money that has an expiration date
if you don't spend this 100 within a
month it's gone forever
an extreme take on inflation as soon as
a camera catches people jaywalking
you can instantly find them if you want
to give people stimulus checks
you can do so instantly to their account
with the press of a button you can set a
limit on how much money a person can
have
or what they're allowed to spend each
specific dollar on you can see how your
economy is performing in the finest of
details in real time
basically china took all the good stuff
about cryptocurrencies
it's all digital you can see all the
transactions its convenience and took
out all the bad stuff like privacy and
decentralization
and although china has mentioned they
intend the digital uin to coexist with
alipay and wechat pay
based on their actions against jack ma
and amp group i wouldn't suspect that to
last very long
although china was the first major
economy to have a digital currency
other nations aren't far behind a survey
found that almost all central banks are
actively researching this idea of a
central bank digital currency or cbdc
60 of them are experimenting with them
and 14
of them are deploying pilot projects
this includes the us
and with the heat coming from china and
crypto i wouldn't be surprised if we see
a digital usd happening soon
well i don't think they have a technical
advantage i think it's more of an
ideological advantage that in a
totalitarian communist society have no
qualms about
getting data on everybody in every way
in every way possible
and that's what i think makes ai
you know a very tricky technology where
even if we're ahead in theory
you know there are a lot of ways we
don't actually want to apply it in the
u.s or in the west
and central bank digital currencies will
be pitched in other countries the same
way it's being pitched in china
it's more convenient we can prevent
fraud and crime we can get stimulus
checks to you instantly
the federal reserve will be able to
control the economy even easier and more
efficiently
think of all the good we can do but like
china this tool is just that
a tool that can be used for good or to
turn things into a real dystopian
nightmare
so will the future of the world look
more decentralized and free or even more
centralized and controlled than it is
right now
it's hard to say i can't see the appeal
of a digital un or
digital dollar and i also don't doubt
people's willingness to trade freedom
for convenience
but we also know that like with the
advent of the printing press
no matter how much the church wanted to
control the spreading of knowledge
democratizing technology like the
printing press and the internet always
finds a way to the individual
decentralized cryptocurrency is out
there now it's time to see if they can
live up to the hype
and the challenge central banks are
putting up against it so the battle
between crypto
china's digital un and other central
banks is still up in the air
and whichever fork we choose will be up
to you
don't forget to check out the sponsor of
today's video mine mine is the smart
data assistant that helps you identify
which companies have your personal data
unless you decide where you want to keep
it
it's free for a limited time it's good
for you it's ridiculously easy to use
and you can check it out with the link
below
if you're new here we make video essays
just like this one every single week on
the most provocative stuff in the world
of business so make sure you subscribe
and turn on that notification bell so
you get notified when new videos come
out
and you can always dislike unsubscribe
and leave me your best hate comments so
you have nothing to lose
if you want more behind the scenes stuff
then the live kind of stuff memes you
can follow me on instagram at jtrand.io
that is going to wrap it up for this
video thank you so much for watching
you've been awesome i've been jake
stay dangerous out there and i will see
you guys in the next one
[Music]
it